how do you know
[Music]
five-four-three-two-one
[Music]
what's up everyone what's up welcome to
simulation I'm your host Don sockin and
we're sitting down with David siwash
today what's that
what's up Alan thanks for coming out of
the show good to be here really
appreciate it I was just at your event
last night you were and it was so fun
you were doing an event about being an
empath and you were teaching us about
being an empath you were teaching us
about nuance in the body energy field we
went pretty deep you did a reading live
and like narrated it and we'll go
through one of those today as well so
like we've been doing this like 10 years
now eight years eight years well depends
I mean by this I've been teaching only
for like a year maybe I've been playing
with taking people's energy into my body
and expressing what it feels like and
what it means for maybe three years and
then I've been going hmm something's up
let me explore for eight or nine years
and that initial moment of something is
up let's talk about that because I think
so many people are kind of at that
moment yeah yeah so okay so we pretty
much understand nothing about energetics
it's very little we barely understand
what happens inside of me and inside of
you how we relate to each other it's
very difficult to understand that and
science isn't really hasn't really got
to that so when we get that sort of
moment of like huh you said something
and I felt something inside of me hmm
yeah so like how do we end up maybe
learning about that more well I don't
want to go back to the premise of what
you just said which is we don't know
much about this stuff
and I guess if by we we mean Western
folks trying to understand it
analytically then I would agree with you
but if you exclude that small category
of people mostly men and mostly in the
last 300 years who decided for reasons
we don't fully understand that if they
couldn't explain it it wasn't real
if we exclude that category of man that
leaves many many people who do have a
really fine understanding of these
subtle experiences okay we're still
talking like probably less than a
billion people on the planet and every
child has an understanding of energy
they just haven't articulated it we just
out outgrow it because we stopped
prioritizing things we can't explain and
we over prioritize things that appear to
give us direct results and so all those
subtle experiences become irrelevant if
you want to reduce a child or an adult
to their the value they create okay so
so children are born with this aperture
that's wide open for signal yes and then
it's slowly closed oh yeah well we could
put it more harshly and say we closed it
for them yeah
culture yeah close it for culture close
it for them and then and then even
though children are born at this even
today I think maybe let's let's try and
put like an amount on this because this
is interesting at least put in a mount
on it maybe China and India in some
places in the East it's likely in
Southeast Asia it's likely higher that
adults apertures are open towards signal
I think that's true but are we talking
about like 25 percent of them you know
because in the West it's probably much
much less right well and I don't know
those cultures very well my experience
in India for the three weeks that I
spent which is nothing was that there
was a general acceptance of the reality
of things that couldn't be explained
mm-hmm and I could feel that hmm in the
air and reincarnation for instance there
is facts for a lot of people it's a
trivial fact
it's not even something to wonder about
in the two weeks I went to China and
again this is totally the opposite of a
scientific experiment and just my two
weeks there I did not feel that same
openness in China I felt the same kind
of constriction I feel here in fact even
more so that that they are so obsessed
but this was just this place as I went
so this is beijing shanghai nanjing the
people are so obsessed with what can be
measured what works what sells how to
get from here to there sounds like go so
be subtle yeah I think they learned that
from us that the subtle experiences are
lost unless those experiences can then
be packaged in an India there's this
general feeling for okayness with not
knowing the ethereal what exists outside
of the metaphysical our metaphysical
understanding of the universe I just can
I can feel people who have a deep
connection to India thrashing about
watching this going who are these two
white men to talk about in general terms
an entire subcontinent and to all of you
I say I hear you and I'm sorry I even
walked in that direction likewise and
but it's still interesting to at least
aim to put a thumb on places in the
world that are doing things away that we
can learn from and that's what we're
trying to do here more than anything
it's not to you know make some a horror
sign meant to be malevolent
generalizations these are meant to be
more insightful generalizations that can
actually hopefully enrich us so so for
first for for both areas of people
across the world that can tuned that can
maybe tap in a little bit more as well
as children that are born into the world
that tap in a little more maybe give us
a like a bit of what have been some of
these really important takeaways for the
aperture being open how to keep the
aperture open well the the the reason
the aperture is closed is because it's
not safe because there's not much space
in it so the goal is not to crack open
people's apertures that could actually
be counterproductive and there are a lot
of people who come to
you wanting to be kind of blown wide
open and that's not necessarily healthy
for them that might throw them more out
of balance the world that I want to see
is a world where we create safe spaces
for people to open their apertures and
we could have a culture that encourages
that right now let's say you're in your
office and your boss is saying something
really passive-aggressive I knew you
wouldn't do that on time and you feel
that physically in your body you can
feel the aggression in that language
mm-hmm is it safe to say hey I felt that
aggression of what you just said in my
body right here and it hurt he's more
often than not he's going to go what the
hell are you talking about he's going to
dismiss you you're going to be cuckoo
you're off if you're a woman saying that
you're gonna be stereotyped as hyper
emotional if you're a man saying that
you're a sense that you're sensitive
you're a wuss what's going on and suck
it up tough it up and so there's a good
reason why the person in that situation
is closed off it's actually safer when
you're secure more and more secure in
yourself then you can say okay I felt
the aggression in that it hurts because
you're less dependent on their reaction
you're more secure in yourself so how do
we create more security in people's own
inner experience how do we create safe
spaces for people to express what's
really going on or even to be accepting
of what is really going on internally
even if they don't express it and how do
we create a culture that allows for that
so it has to do with safety it has to do
a safety yeah aperture the remaining
open has to do with safety 100% okay so
what I feel from my boss in that
situation or from anyone that I'm
encountering in an interpersonal
connection it's almost certainly that
culture is in making the space unsafe
because I can't express how I feel
without being a overhype early emotional
female or a male that's a would yeah
seeing as such and you carry there is a
space
there is a level of awareness one can
reach or one can say to oneself I'm
having this experience it's intense and
unpleasant this experience is okay I'm
here for myself and I'm not going to
express it to the person in front of me
that is possible but that is tightrope
walking for a lot of people and it's not
cool for me to say just because I can do
it you should be able to do it actually
the first step to being able to get to
that place in my experience is actually
to express it even in messy ways oh I
really don't like that and you're going
to create a mess yeah so unless you're
secure in that it really might not
actually be so safe to open up Oh things
are changing more and more people are
saying well we need we need this we need
to tune up our humanity I mean we're in
San Francisco right now and every third
conversation is about how to use
technology to enhance our humanity which
I mean I like that conversation I like
taking part of that conversation but it
sort of skips the obvious conversation
which is how do we tap into our existing
humanity it's already so incredible and
underutilized we don't need technology
we need space I mean like yesterday we
had people put the cellphones away and
literally like spend half an hour tuning
into the experience of another person
and I would be surprised if there wasn't
at least a few people whose minds were
blown by the subtle experiences they
were able to have of another person's
mine was yeah I know so that's all we
need in fact it took putting the
cellphones away and getting into a quiet
space having a container for it having a
guide saying this is okay and then
trusting that I can take you into that
space and take you out of that space and
in that Wow your humanity is already
enhanced yeah so technology augments
humanity great what is actually within
humanity in the first place that we can
tap into and better understand and like
you said you made this space for us
yesterday and it was great having all
the devices put away off and just really
far away
no no nothing was being no communication
to satellites or or radio wave towers at
all that was fantastic
and then there was also the you brought
us into the space through a grounding
exercise as well and I think maybe we
unpack this a little bit because there
was something else that I wanted to talk
about and if I remember I'll come back
to maybe that means we'll link up with
it later
with you grounding us into the space
there was this connection to earth I
thought that was really interesting
there was also these moments of like
wiping away tell us about this let's see
well one we started yesterday I had
people put their feet on the grounds and
then imagine everything in their body
from the top of their head all the way
down that wasn't theirs and then
releasing it down through their body and
into the center of the earth and out
through it goes out through the heels or
through the bottom of the feet and
there's no theory behind this this is
simply what I do every single morning to
stay within my own field as much as
possible we had a room full of sensitive
people and those people inevitably
including me are bringing stuff into
that space that isn't theirs and it MUX
up the signal so I wanted us to let go
of that stuff so when we tuned into the
other we were clearer about what's ours
what's theirs and what isn't even either
one of ours and it is also grounding
because you're connecting to the earth
then the shaking off is much more about
releasing it's just like we've animals
do this on their own you pick up energy
and you want to let it go
shake sorry about the sound that might
mistake that might have mean so that's
simple as that it's instinctual you know
we look we've lost many of our instincts
but shaking your body when you picked up
stuff is shake it off
exactly and then those the dogs do the
whole like from the tail all the way to
the head yeah that long shake not just
to you know to dry off but also to just
release energy at least energy there's
there's a good amount of animals that do
that type of I wouldn't be surprised if
every animal didn't do that I think it's
probably universal yeah except humans
because we get up here and then we are
stuck here well we we somehow came into
the delusion and again this is the this
is the well-intentioned mistake of white
men in the last three or 400 years who
came into the delusion that we had to
solve everything with our minds and
we've been trapped in that delusion ever
since and ironically and the great irony
of language we called this the
Enlightenment when it was could not have
been more unenlightened to think that
you could just figure stuff out with
your head and everybody else knows that
that's absurd in defense of the
Enlightenment it was fighting against an
even more in main thought structure
which was you know you just all hail the
Catholic Church or something so okay
that's that's stupid I accept so now
we're gonna think for ourselves but we
forgot the embodied experience and now
we're getting back to it I think it was
almost necessary for us to go through
this Enlightenment of realizing that we
can leverage our brains for such amazing
feats of Technology and engineering and
now the we're swinging in the other way
which is like wait what about all the
emotions what about the feelings what
about the energy and then now those two
things as we swing back in that
direction and then end up combining in
the future it's just gonna be yeah I
agree with that I like that story but
it's going to take the this is a strong
word the subjugation of the analytical
male technology driven Minds to the
unpredictable feminine flowing mm-hmm
spectacular unfolding that is possible
if we tap into our emotions
and we've done it completely the
opposite way so it's going to take a lot
for tech driven analytical men and tech
driven analytical women who are
embodying their masculine yeah to
release the grip on their overarching
thesis which is we're gonna figure this
out with the mind and to allow and
eventually bow before the deeper reality
that we're not going to figure out [ __ ]
with our minds and that our minds are
there in service of this deeper
unpredictable messy embodied truth and
even as I say that you can feel like the
subtle vibration in the air right like
things shift yeah hey that's it feel it
yeah yeah yeah to me I felt a whoa like
an O yeah yeah because that I think
maybe that uh vibrates quite deeply
through the san francisco technology
sector there's a lot of male and females
here that are embodying their logic in
their in their mind and that nothing
wrong with it's a dancing us in many
ways it's it's solving a lot of problems
related to our health related to our
communication but it's also harming us
and communication in some way and in
health but I want to say that maybe or
maybe you I think the way that you place
that was maybe a little bit heavier on
the feminine and the energy yes yeah is
that is that that's abdominus yeah mind
the mind will combine with that but
it'll be a heavier amount on the
feminine energy moving forward it's it's
like the mat the healthy masculine
energy creates a boundary makes it safe
and protects you know like this is
what's cool this is what's not cool and
I'm going to make sure it's safe here
but then the feminine flows in the
direction needs to flow
and unpredictable you said it's
definitely unpredictable what happens in
our bodies on a moment-to-moment basis
is not to be predicted and the moment
you try to predict it you'll dissociate
you'll lose your connection to your body
so as you tune into that inner
experience there's a truth there that
can express itself only if it's safe to
do so and if it's allowed the
opportunity to lead another way of
saying this is that love conquers all
mm-hmm I can't I
I've been going into corporations and
I've been talking to people who leave
companies and the the framework is
always the same or almost always the
same I have a problem and I want to
figure out how to solve it and what can
you tell me that will help me figure out
how to solve it and there's a perfectly
understandable framework and I'm not
saying that framework is bad always but
the deeper problems don't resolve
themselves within that framework
I would reframe it and go there's an
experience happening here how can I
embody it or experience it and allow the
truth of it to emerge through me or
through us it looks a lot more like
inspiration or a ha or a WoW or oh my
god and then it does look like okay I
crack this code so moment to moment
being okay with not knowing it gives us
divinity gives us power within us it was
a so Kanis yeah it gives us that
unpredictability that feminine energy
but then so then maybe the masculine
energy was a little bit more like the
boundary that you're talking about
so you set up some boundaries yesterday
I thought this was interesting
both being a drop of water as well as
being in the ocean at the same time so
we're all drops of water but we're all
in the ocean together so when can the
drop of water put up a boundary so that
way all the energy from the ocean is not
coming in to the water but also when can
the drop of water open up the boundary
and let the ocean come to it practice
and what does that look like in practice
as well give us a good example of that
well I think empaths
people who feel other people's feelings
are by definition more open to the
experiences of others in their own body
and most of us have had a lot of trouble
setting up boundaries yeah so it looks
like two things one is setting up actual
physical boundaries and spaces meaning
this conversation is causing me a lot of
anxiety it's not even my anxiety you're
anxious I'm taking it on I'm now
removing myself from this conversation
that's a very healthy thing to do for an
empath yeah it's also very difficult
because part of being an empath is the
compulsion to help or to make sure the
other person is okay and they don't want
to hurt the person by rejecting them so
for the empath so much of working
through boundaries is a function of
learning to be okay with hurting people
the other half is energetic boundaries
and that's like I can do it now and for
those of you who can see cool stuff by
looking I'm imagining a force field or
fields protecting me and it's harder to
get through with other people's energy
into that field now I'm going to drop it
and I feel much more vulnerable
that field won't help you in deep
relationships do not trick yourself into
thinking that if you just imagine a
force field somehow your whole
relationship with your mother will be
transformed the unconscious need to
connect with the mother is way greater
than the conscious ability to project an
imaginary force field around your body
so but it is a good trick in
interactions like day-to-day
interactions then the ultimate boundary
the apex of boundary setting is
self-awareness which maybe isn't
technically a boundary but the more I
become aware of what's happening in my
body subtly at moments moments and how
other people's energies are affecting
mine the more I'm comfortable with those
experiences and the less I need to block
them out and I can allow it just to flow
through me and that the only way to get
there is by the subtle and rigorous work
of tuning into your own physiological
experience moments a moment and or doing
really deep healing work because as you
tune into your body you're gonna start
resisting most people will start having
resistance I don't want to experience
that okay well what is that resistance
why don't you want to experience that
and if you follow that path of
resistance it will lead you toward real
pain and as you process that pain you'll
open up more and more and more stuff
will be able to come through you so this
is so self awareness will help us not
need to set up these mysteries but into
but yes but don't let don't don't make
don't take that to mean that oh I'm
gonna stop setting up boundaries and
cultivate self awareness now you're
asking for trouble yeah set up
boundaries until and unless you no
longer need them yeah yeah and so self
awareness can be described as
understanding how you are being impacted
at its smallest yeah we're loudest like
like you know obvious example you sit in
a movie theater somebody sits next to
you
never met him before and you start
feeling all this anxiety and then you
look over and they're really anxious
just becoming aware of that experience
empowers you yeah yeah and now instead
of a problem Wow you went to go see a
movie and you just learned that you're
sensitive to the experiences the people
next to you that's a revelation that's a
good one and then I think you made one
similar to that last night just like
someone a friend that you're meeting up
with bringing their like teenage
daughter with them and the daughters
like or even like younger even kid is
like running around and like all giddy
and like excited and you're like wow why
do I feel so giddy and excited it's like
that's coming from there and that's how
me but yeah being aware of that is so
interesting and that can help us a lot
with with everything that's going on in
our lives I think it especially can be
helpful in relationships both
professional business relationships and
also with our moms with our lovers with
our family and even with the world in
general just being more tuned in there
were so many things that we that we
touched on I know we still want to do
our our demo and our reading and maybe
we talked about this a bit because we
did a good chunk on the on the sensitive
man we did a good chunk on that it's
gonna be an interesting transition in
the next couple of decades what about
the idea of empathy verse intuition
they're super connected for me at the
edge of empathy is the surrender of the
self for another person's experience so
when I when I tune into somebody I give
over my body to the experience they're
having as best as I can and it the word
surrender feels apt I'm surrendering to
it it's a feminine quality that I'm
embodying
and as I'm in that place of surrender to
another person's experience I'm getting
all sorts of information I'm getting
information that could be measured very
easily and scientifically like anxiety
levels I'll bet you that my anxiety is
rising with their anxiety in ways it
could be demonstrably measured and for
scientists watching at home please help
me figure out how to do that I'm eager
for it but it doesn't stop there I also
and here's where I start crossing
threshold in our culture but not one in
my own body I start hearing things I
start seeing things I start hearing
other people's voices I can occasionally
have a a real 360 multi-sensory
experience of what it's like to be
another person past present future all
of visions of their childhood future not
so much but past and present all visions
of their child that I'll seek people in
their lives I'll hear thoughts in their
heads sometimes most the time I'm in my
body having a physiological experience
of what it's like to be them but
sometimes [ __ ] just comes through that
is inexplicable and I surrender to it so
it's like where's that line between
empathy and intuition I think that there
is none mm-hmm and I would draw further
it's like empathy intuition psychic
phenomena what this is a blur mmhmm yeah
and then what does it look like to have
my energy versus your energy and then
have you be able to tap into someone's
childhood well this is me I feel very me
right now I'm centered in myself mm-hmm
and I can just tune into what it's like
to be you mm-hmm and I feel just right
now a little disoriented truthfully I'm
trying to hold it down but it's hard and
I feel a little floaty and that's what I
feel like as I tune in to your energy I
think there was a switch in your vibe
when we started talking about the
masculine feminine and I said that the
masculine needs to learn
to subjugate itself to be unpredictable
feminine that's a revolutionary
statement then when it's spoken by an
articulate man is hard to stomach for
other articulate men yeah it's totally
true
I think there's a lot of humility that
has to shine through the happy up to us
anymore we've taken this I don't know if
we've driven the the bus off the cliff
yet but we're certainly driving off the
cliff and all we know how to do is take
measurements of our speed and direction
and calculate that we're screwed and
that's the perfect time in a spiritual
sense to surrender and what is it do you
surrender to you surrender to what is
the embodied truth of the moment as it
unfolds and that can't be decided upon
that could only be surrendered to so
this idea I felt this or I sensed it
disoriented you created this shift it
ungrounded you and but it also created
this kind of floaty feeling mm-hmm
I didn't I actually came right into my
Center I'm like yeah that's I believe
that [ __ ] this is awesome yeah I'm
saying it well yeah
for me and for me I'm just trying to
understand what the exact balance will
be that will be required no balance but
yeah the other surrenders the balance
the other aspect of it is just surrender
to the unpredictability of where the
masculine-feminine will intertwine and
how much they will engage with each
other and where they will sort of
permeate throughout civilization and
just be totally okay with where that is
where that's going and what it will be
like but also want to help guide it in
certain but even you know I want to push
against you a little bit big yes please
they're still in you and it's very
common
this conception that we can figure out
how to do this like okay there's this
force and there's this force and I'm
gonna figure out where I play in this
and how these forces fit together and
somehow balance them and this is not
what I believe you know and what is it
then
it's more like what is emerging through
me that is my part to do and you feel me
playing in that space when I'm
channeling this kind of truth okay he's
doing that that's his role this is part
of his job it's not because I thought to
myself I'm somebody who's going to speak
like this and how do I train myself to
be articulate enough and in tune enough
to do that and I'm going to spend five
years doing that this is not how I've
approached this this is more like okay
I've gone through enough of my own
garbage that there's now this space and
from this space is emerging this stuff
these words these concepts these ideas
the sensitivity this ability to teach
and it's I'm going with it I'm going
with it now I have to invoke the
masculine to be like this is the line
don't screw with that I do have goals
sometimes I want to achieve this with
that for sure but the underlying flow is
in charge and the masculine part of me
is just using a machete to clear the
path and in the feminist planting
flowers along the way I'm the path no
the feminine is fierce
now the feminine is fierce the feminine
has the machete - no the feminine does
not have a machete what is it like it's
like Shakti it's it's the it's the you
ever walk into a room and encounter a
goddess and go oh that's what we're
talking about its forceful its powerful
what it isn't is analytical and
clear-eyed and like trying to figure
thing out things out really clearly it's
Beyonce Sasha Fierce
Sasha Fierce no that's her alter ego
that's Beyonce's alter ego Sasha Fierce
yeah so so yes no it's not about balance
it is ultimately about balance but the
balance comes on the other side of
surrender does not come by trying to
figure out the balance we're talking
about it comes from surrender yeah okay
so the analytical mind trying to figure
out the balance isn't right but the one
that does work anyway
it's it's one that surrenders to
whatever the balance ends up being yeah
there you have okay so now let's let's
revisit that couple minute ago sentence
so let's say okay the surrendered
feeling of whatever the balance ends up
being of civilization whatever we end up
doing with that with the masculine
feminine amazing at the same time
there's got to be a little bit of egoic
play as well with trying to set goals
and manifest goals that's going to
that's part of it that's one of the
things we're doing and there's nothing
wrong in theory with setting goals but
there's a lot wrong in practice you know
god save us from a bunch of white men
getting together in a room and plotting
a course for the future this has not
gone historically well this is a real
problem you know and and and how many
rooms of men are getting together going
I'm going to solve this but they're not
even connected to their heart they
haven't had a feeling in 10 years and so
what is the this they're solving for the
first this I would want them to solve
for if they were talking to me would be
how do I get back in here
and what they'll discover is that it
really hurts it really hurts in here
really hurts in here because a lot of
people are hurting there's a lot of
things breaking and if you're gonna be
in tune with your own heart you're gonna
start feeling a lot of pain I think the
reason why are you laughing I don't
understand why he understands why and I
think and I think I'll explain why and I
think you'll understand Ron I know you
might not be close enough to my energy
right now to feel why I'm laughing
because of all of the centuries of
what's come what's happened and just how
like just running around with like a
hammer and like just like shattering
what's going on is just really difficult
for people to take in and I mean it's
even difficult for me right now and like
I'm more I'm more tuned into the
meditation in the feminine and the
feeling than a lot of men are and it's
really difficult for me and and that
that's that's that I'm what I'm feeling
with that is now how much more difficult
it is for the vast majority then that
aren't even tuned in in the first place
to hear something like this and then be
like oh how do i how do i how do I do
that why is that important I want to I
want to address that then because how do
you do that first if you if if you read
if the sentence I'm not in my heart and
I don't even know what that's like
really resonates for you and you're one
of those people who goes around thinking
about how to solve problems all the time
and believing that your ultimate value
is in the scale of problem you are
solving then that's a wonderful place to
start and that's where you're at right
now and that's perfectly okay and then
the question becomes how do I slowly
gently make my way back into my heart
and the answer to that is going to be
different for every person there's not
going to be a one-size-fits-all and your
intuition even if you're totally
disconnected will show up for you
once you start asking that question
you'll discover you have one friend who
you can be that much more honest with
and he or she will be able to hold your
disconnection better than anybody else
it's that person you feel just a little
bit more comfortable with on a deep
level and you spend just a little more
time with that person now you open up a
little bit and then there's these voices
that show up oh should I be doing this
is this right I don't know ooh can I
hold those voices in a way I didn't
before
it's the any man or anybody this is not
man or woman this is masculine and
feminine we're talking about anyone
who's shut off the inner life the
emotional life in order to solve
problems
still has within them circulating deep
experiences and those deep experiences
will come up if you give them a little
space and tell them it's okay
now eventually those deep experiences if
you are disconnected will overwhelm you
have no doubt if you're going to go all
the way and that is by all the way I
mean out of your analytical mind and
fully into your body and into your heart
you will be overwhelmed you will be torn
asunder at some point and right before
you're torn asunder I hope that you have
the maturity to surrender the keys like
okay I can't drive this bus anymore I
need to go work on myself
it's time
so one of the easiest ways is to find
people around you that you can go deeper
that's great yeah mm-hmm and then when
you do keep going keep going it's like
there's a little there's a little
strands every one of us has a little
strand that connects us back to our
heart and it might not be in my top B
introspection it might just be these
little rays of light okay I see
something this feels good this feels new
this feels fresh I'm gonna go into it
and then you keep following that it's
not gonna be a straightforward path and
if you try to map it out you're gonna
fail it's by definition going to snake
and get weird and interesting and
unpredictable so it's gonna challenge
your sense of certainty your sense of
clarity your need for control you need
to understand and slowly or maybe
sometimes suddenly you can let go of
those things and the rewards are
incredible you know I that I'm all for
purpose but I'm not so much for people
sitting around going I'm gonna figure
out my purpose and do it that tends to
be an unsustainable thrusting of energy
out and then trying to hold it when it's
there it creates a lot of shame and
guilt and how can I live my purpose the
opposite approach like okay I'm lost I
don't know what my purpose is I'm
floating in the ether
that's okay how can I be where I'm at
mm-hm that's that's what I advocate and
the more you're out the more you are
where you're the more you are where
you're at the more you're on your way
back home deep stuff yeah to me the
being okay with not knowing what your
purpose is is okay with being uncertain
and feels like as long as there's some
sort of there's some sort of like
you're moving forward still with that
okayness rather than digressing then
eventually though you could even dump
that model what if you're not moving
forward what if you're irrelevant what
if you're aimless what if you let go of
the map that says I'm making progress or
I'm being productive from winning you
can feel the shift that happens whoa
it's like a void we're standing over
well that void was always there can I
make friends with it without telling
myself that it's good if I make friends
with it and bad if I don't okay hold on
let me let me challenge because isn't
being aimless also a huge concern we
found ourselves as a bunch of monkeys
now in control of this rock and if we're
completely aimless malevolent figures
can just come and take control and
inflict a lot of suffering well I don't
feel aimless I'm just saying aimlessness
the acceptance of aimlessness as a path
as a step along the path to surrender
purpose growth expansion and then the
full embodiment of your own truth
aimlessness might be a wonderful step so
a lot of people will come to me and go
like I don't I don't know I feel so lost
as if that's a problem then I want to
give them a high five so to welcome five
welcome welcome welcome to lost you know
it's a great place to be after having
believed you were found all those times
because you were doing what everyone
told you to do yeah yeah yeah much
better to be lost than it is to be think
that you are being purposely driven by
what other people are telling you
exactly so so I'm just and the map that
we all have around productivity or
achievement or winning or success I like
questioning that map I do have a map but
it doesn't end with achievements you
know it ends with collaboration
connection the full embodiment of our
gifts a world where I can walk out that
door and feel like whoever I encounter
not in words truly has my best interest
at heart what would that take what would
that take you what I'm talking about
this the surrender of the
conceptualization of how the world needs
to be run for the increased experience
of what it's like to be a human moments
in moments and for those of us who are
capable of holding other people's
experiences it's on us to show up and
say this is what is true for you as I
experience it in you and I'm gonna hold
that with you non-judgmentally and
ideally with love mm-hmm and for those
of us who are not there yet to embody
who we are fully it's incumbent on us to
acknowledge that to ourselves and to
have the courage to step into being lost
and trust that there are people here and
not just people beautiful forces at work
that are there to hold you as you are
lost this is fun to talk about by the
way this is the first interview I've
done like this this is the first time
somebody's dug into this stuff with me
it's a blast thank you for letting me go
there
bless you do seriously yeah we need you
yeah and thank you and Ron and I are
yeah we were we love holding this type
of conversation on the show so yeah but
don't ever forget the you knows of you
know you talk about the all the
beautiful help that we get you know just
don't ever dismiss the dark villain
among us did just high dark villain you
have dark villain yes you're welcome
here too I have my own dark villain
sometimes I can be with that guy and
hang out with them and for the dark
villains within you and the dark
villains in the world let it let us hold
you and it is on us mmm the people who
have made friends with our internal dark
villains to create a safe space so that
you don't have to hide your villain
anymore
and you can hang out with us under the
tree and eat nice fruit see it's the
acknowledgment of the dark villain being
a part of each of us individually as
well as collectively and then being okay
with the dark villain eating fruit with
us under the tree yeah it's also
important to let the dark villain be the
dark villain and see what you can learn
from the dark villain yeah as you go
forward with love conquers all and love
everybody you know just die good luck
with that
harmonious I don't believe in that
actually I don't I don't I mean I I
believe in that underlying principle but
I I'm not a love junkie and I don't go
out into the world saying like if I just
love this person enough all problems
will be solved so you acknowledge the
killer inside the killer
well you're bringing the killer out you
obviously want us to deal with him so hi
killer I want I'm the killer that you're
bringing forth I want to create space
for it's okay that's the extent to which
I'm currently able to love the killer is
just by holding space for that killer
and as I feel my own energy start to
wobble with the intensity with what
you're bringing it forth then I go this
is what I can handle right now and there
are other people who can handle more of
it than I can and hopefully that killer
that you're bringing up will meet those
people who can handle more of it I can
handle a lot but not everything in keep
up the good work counting on ya that
that was so interesting
it's really it's really cool to see and
feel what it's like to have like that
maybe bronze more you know his or his
realistic feeling of like the darkness
and the villain and the killer in the
sense brought to you and you going whoa
that was I'm wobbling I'm wobbling a bit
and like I'll meet it and I'll see it
and I'll feel it but that's what I can
do with it right all right that's our
timer
okay so let's um let's let's jump into a
session we don't have to follow this
exactly how long is that that's 15 but
okay we can do 15 okay I like that I
like the timer so by way of introduction
first of all would it be okay if I took
off my sweater I'm feeling a little hot
absolutely yeah it's so much fun
it's such a trip Oh perfect okay it's
basically already there
I'll link you up right right here there
we go
all right let's twist towards each other
okay it doesn't matter how you sit and
sit however you're comfortable that you
can also sit like me if you like yes
who are you what you mean who are you
what makes you say that just uh it's
very interesting you know Thanks yeah I
have this overwhelming sensation to want
to get to know you better
oh thank you appreciate that I'm David
from LA I live in New York I used to
direct documentaries and commercials I
started doing intuitive readings led to
this psychic stuff and then performance
art and then along the way I had to
learn how to handle it and I I am good
at it and good at articulating what's
happening then there's also this like
radical anarchist in me
who wants real transformation in this
world not conceptual transformation but
actual transformation and I'm
integrating in my own being those two
strands political and the spiritual and
sharing what I got as clearly as I can
so that it brings it about simple don't
want kids that have any I'm single I'm
broke I like theater a little bit of a
throw ditch I have a sister two parents
broke up with my girlfriend of five
years in January view a sense yeah
thank you for your welcome we're good
what are we even filming that whole time
yeah yeah it's good
reel reel is good now what are we what
are we about to do what is an empathic
reading okay so what I'm gonna do is in
a minute
is open up the space in myself
and then invite you don't have to do
anything I do all the work and buy your
energy into my body and I'm also going
to at the same time as I'm inviting your
energy and I'm also in a sense going
into your energy field as well and with
these two channels of information I
surrender my body to the experience I'm
having of your experience and as you'll
see in a minute my body will start to
shift into these different contortions
or into these different expressions
I'm not consciously shifting my body my
body is shifting automatically and then
I am decoding what I'm experiencing
mmm-hmm
the words I'm using to describe the
experiences I'm having are as good as
anybody or my ability to describe subtle
experiences with language I'm pretty
articulate and good at it but
nonetheless I will often probably always
say this when it could have been that
and I what else
so you're both allowing the my energy to
come through you but also your energy to
come through me it doesn't feel like I'm
letting my energy come through you it's
more like some kind of information
seeking aspect of myself is drawing is
going into you and feeling things out
and then I'm also in fact I'm preventing
I'm not I'm not projecting my energy
into you I don't believe that I'm doing
that so there's two sides of it though
there's the side that comes in from me
to you and then from you to me
yeah there is a part that I'm traveling
to you and as a part that's just
receptor so they're receptive purely
receptive part takes place in my chest
as I experience it
I literally envision in my chest these
like my own energy parting ways to allow
for this I also I'm going to take off my
necklace which I use to protect myself
everyone always asks so I will tell you
it's an e force plus I get paid nothing
for advertising for it and I happen to
love it it's the best protection I found
a force plus so yeah any questions
before we start or anything else do you
think you need to know or people would
want to know yeah maybe the do nothing
the only thing the only thing that you
that I can to do is I can't try and be
with your feelings yeah I mean you could
if you wanted and I would feel that
probably and then it would just become
weird some tricksters do that stuff to
me they come up and they get a reading
and they're like I'm gonna jujitsu you
so I start feeling all this weird stuff
right
it's just it just it's the one thing you
can do that would muck it up in a sense
yeah yeah otherwise you can pretty much
think or feel anything you want yeah
yeah yeah I you show up to the readings
as you are cool all right and then
I don't have to do this but I do it
because it makes me more likely to be
accurate can I have your hands and then
I start by how you're feeling at this
very moment
and I feel as you really open there's
still a little bit woozy
I can feel as you what feels like my
Crown Chakra really open I'm open to
more information than I am usually and
it feels nice I also feel light and a
little ungrounded and that's how I feel
you feeling right now I think at the end
it'll be great if you say what resonated
and especially if you say what didn't
resonate because that's really useful
for people to hear I do not claim to be
perfect at all this is an inexact
science I will and also you you make it
clear to not get feedback as yes oh crap
yup my eyes are closed so I don't like
watching because then I'll start
thinking is this right is this wrong and
I don't even like people do it but I
prefer if they didn't go hah or yeah
because then I start integrating my need
for validation into the reading
okay so that's how you are right now
have your hand again this is just to
help me tune back in and I'm gonna go
from how you're feeling right now to
what's been going on with you generally
beyond this moment not in this moment
but what's happening with you generally
and then I get a very different feeling
so the way you're feeling right now is
not a normal feeling for you normally
there's a couple different things going
on
you can see I'm bouncing a little bit
this bounces excitement I feel as you
excited about the things that are
happening I also feel as you can see
with my hands like I have to be a bit
careful I can't just go headlong into
all of my excitement I have to make sure
I parcel out my excitement delicately
and carefully what else is going on
there's really this giddiness in you I
felt this at the event yesterday when I
do readings I certainly do have access
to information that I'm not getting
directly within the reading itself when
I do the readings I like to share what
information I'm getting separately from
within the readings so that people can
see how those two streams of information
line up or don't so but this sense of
like real giddiness about things was
apparent in you when you came to that
event yesterday you obviously excited to
be there as you said and now I'm feeling
that as a general way or your being in
the world they're being excited you're
being open and you're wanting to ingest
more and more information this I can
feel that in you I also know that in you
as somebody who likes interviewing
people asking questions of people it's
like give me more give me more I want to
I want to figure it all out I want all
of it I want to understand everything I
can feel my brain like wanting to just
going on with you then there's a
relative comfort actually with not
knowing like okay I'm curious I'll
figure this stuff out as it comes like I
might not know everything and that's
pretty okay let me learn let me go here
let me curiosity a really healthy
curiosity which can edge into confusion
sometimes but you don't feel overwhelmed
by the confusion I think I've probably
confused you more than most people
what else is going on generally you seem
to be in a really good state generally
positive open to things there's some
joyfulness coming through you and that's
that's what's been going on with you
generally now I'm going to go deeper
and there is within you at a much deeper
level this tension we touched on it in
our conversation earlier and now I can
feel it in my body as I tuned in to you
it's this you have a really interesting
relationship to control because on the
one hand you do have this lightness and
openness and you're an explorer and
you're willing to go where things take
you but on the other hand there is a
part of you that's really holding on
quite tight and needs to be in control I
go into that it's a lot of keeping with
our conversation but now I feel it
there's a lot of determination and
willpower in you you have this lightness
but there is to quote your partner over
there there's a killer in you too and
it's like I've got to figure this out I
really have to do this I really need to
show up what is my purpose I am doing
this this is very deep stuff in you I'm
going to go even deeper and the source
of that is I feel it you know I'm tuning
into my own heart - David because I'm
about to say something that's intense
and I want to be present for it the the
source of that need to show up or be
strong that determination is fear
and it's it's not all encompassing
you're not controlled by your fear but
it is a major part of what's holding you
a little bit tense like this the
determination and hyper focus originates
in fear but you are more than just
determined and hyper focused you are
also open and playful and adventurous so
these two central tensions this
exploratory nature and this fearful
controlling nature coexist I'm gonna
spend a little more time in this feeling
of fear that's so deep in you
it feels like the kind of fear one would
feel in a situation that is out of
control taking place around you and the
only thing you can do in that situation
is to really figure out everything
that's going on so I'm having this
vision of you as a kid in chaos the
chaos isn't a directed at you you're not
the victim of it directly but it's so
chaotic that you can only survive by
going into a place where you are taking
into account everything and because of
your natural curiosity who you are
anyway those two things come together
and join this natural curiosity with
this fearful need to understand
everything to call you a control freak
would be unfair that you are in some
ways like me an understanding freak you
don't need to control it but your way of
controlling is to make sure you
understand it and once you understand
that you feel safe okay and then I'm
gonna go past the fear into who you are
at your core and in my experience
everyone literally everyone that I've
ever read has a core essence and it's
beyond the emotional realm it's who we
are as we incarnated in this lifetime in
our nature and it's like an archetype
and for you it's very much the adventure
you can see what I'm doing with my hands
it's I want more I want to bring in more
experiences I want to gather and collect
experiences and then I want to share
them just exactly what you're doing with
your life as I understand it so you're
in tune in that sense I want to bring in
this bring in that maybe collector is a
better word than Explorer but the
intersection of collector and Explorer
so I feel myself as you traveling having
all these crazy and fun and amazing and
interesting experiences bringing them in
and integrating them and then there's
this flow it's not just for you it's
like the
is out as I said language is really an
exact here but I think you get the gist
and I'm not having an experience of
light which I'm having an experience in
my body and the language I'm using is
not channeled it's just my best and my
best attempt to describe what it is I'm
feeling so it's it's not perfect it's an
exact no there's a really good chance
that something I said didn't resonate or
wasn't true and if that's the case I
would just advise you to let it go and
much rather have you let go of these
things that I said that don't resonate
then hold on to them and try to make
them make sense
however if what I said did resonate then
I would suggest for you that you start
in your own way going into that fear
this is not Universal advice for those
watching at home not everyone needs to
go into their place of greatest
vulnerability sometimes actually it's
healthy to avoid it but in your
particular case Alan as I tuned into
what would be of service to you I go
straight into that feeling of fear so in
other words whatever you're afraid of
doesn't have to be super intense it
could be things you're just a little
afraid of it would benefit you you in
particular not everyone watching to walk
into that fear and first it's going to
be really difficult so you don't have to
go into the most intense fears you can
go into just things that make you a
little scared and then oh okay you're
gonna find that you can handle it and
then there'll be a little more fear and
then it'll pass through you and then
you'll be ready for the next year and
the more you kind of go into these fears
one after another the more you'll
process the underlying experience that
is at the cause of those fears and the
lighter you will be you're already
pretty light but you'll be even lighter
and more joyous in your adventurousness
and your collection of experiences
and that's my reading
take your time
breathing's good to
the collector collected a collect flow
to collect flow yeah
make a log of it so that other people
can access it as they need as well
that's a gift in the fear the fear
it's both something that I just wanted
to choke the living [ __ ] out of but also
something that I want to be with and
like be okay with that fear sure you
could try a third one you could try
being not okay with it not choking the
living [ __ ] out of it just being
uncomfortable yeah
letting it just make me feel comfy yeah
which which when I was diving in a bit I
was starting to let it make me feel
uncomfortable
yeah and as I say that I can feel my
whole body going yes so just you don't
know if it's not all or nothing
that determination that you have that we
talked about in the reading you can use
that to put you into places of mild
discomfort but you don't need to go
overboard yeah I like the mild
discomfort actually I think it's a
direct way to grow yeah yeah yeah the
edge it's edge and then I like that edge
sometimes that can be a little
overwhelming then go back and then pull
back and then fear I mean some people
need to jump headlong into their most
scary things but I wouldn't advise that
as a general principle there's a lot to
be said for somebody very beautiful said
to me face your fears and then recover
little at a time yeah come back to your
cell that's good face your fears then
recover yeah no more we don't need a
world anymore where people are yelling
at you to go headlong into your greatest
fear and overcome it this is not good
advice like you said there was that
little bit of us like the string that
you can like slowly pull towards like
having an emotional experience with
someone diving deep into what it feels
like to connect with them and what
they're feeling at the moment
similar to fear like walk up to that
edge be with the edge enjoy the presence
go back recover go back to the edge
experience
the code the collector the Explorers
really interesting and then the
connector as well collector and
connector as well as really interesting
holding these experiences of collection
of wisdom for other people it's a is it
was interesting to feel you feeling did
you feel anything it's like
I don't know what it's like I need to do
it more to understand it more yeah
did you feel a subtle kind of little
mist and yeah some sort of yeah yes some
people do it was something and I also
felt that when we were doing our
one-on-ones yesterday with the person
you're paired with totally because I was
the one that was receiving them as well
and so like I received first then they
received me so there was a total like
mmm that like I almost envisioned it as
a like you said a mist that's part of it
and the other part of its kind of like
this just like an outline of them as an
energetic being itself and the pulsing
and vibrating so so tapping into that as
well as receiving that
who's givin you a reading it's a guy
named Paul Selig you did a reading for
me years ago that was very similar in
style to the one I just did for you it's
on camera actually I haven't released
the tape but it's I have it actually I
might have it on my Vimeo page back when
I was a professional director I've gone
to so many psychics and intuitive so I
like it I used to go to three or four a
day I've been home readings tarot
readings I did a tarot reading I had a
tarot reading I don't do them well I do
them but for fun I had I had a tarot
reading just yesterday at the center SF
I mean I like it yeah of course you do
yes yeah I like it I got some good at
height Y esterday for my my reading I
feel compelled to say something to the
people watching this who are pretty
convinced I'm full of [ __ ] or who think
that I must have cold read you and then
said what I knew to be true in some
dramatic way or that what I'm saying is
so generic it could apply to anyone or
that I'm just delusional I just want to
say for those people who believe that
you're more than welcome
like I appreciate that you're watching
that you've made it this far I'm happy
to have that be believed and I will keep
showing up and I hope that you keep
showing up with your skepticism I think
we need both yeah we yeah we do I'm glad
that you address that that's an
important thing to address and then I
want to say by way of my competitive
side I have been begging begging
scientists that I meet to help me
explain this like everyone for people
who study parapsychology in a real way
like Rupert Sheldrake who I love I had a
I asked him to help me to UCLA I've been
working with this neuroscientist there
or neuroscientist PhD I'm reading about
the science of empathy so I'm I'm like
not just willing but eager to submit
myself to Sirius analytic academic
rigorousness because if I am delusional
I promise you I want to know
yeah and then also the scientific
reading that you have coming up on
Wednesday yeah right
so you'll be strapped into eg so will
the person that you're reading
other than this neuroscientist from UCLA
will be monitoring what's going on
she'll be giving a talk about what she
thinks might be what she thinks might be
going on and so this is a way for kind
of some of the skepticism to get a
little bit of objective data so that'll
be interesting so you're we're totally
you know open to exploring that and
seeing what it ends up being they'll be
really exciting I'm glad that that you
address that at the end because I think
a lot of the statements can be viewed as
like general statements but also they
are like kind of finely tuned to a
degree about the what person I don't
want to ask a question about you
deciding to go you know deeper into what
is there then you go deeper into what is
there deeper into someone's essence how
do you pick those things feels like I'm
going like an onion peeling or maybe a
better analogy is diving deeper and
deeper and deeper the way I'm actually
doing it is using my minds to orient so
I'll literally say something like what
else's needs to be seen and then my body
will move in such in such a way or now
I'm gonna go deeper and then I actually
just feel like I'm going deeper there
are these strands of energy that I'm
following so I can feel that
determination in you and I have an
intuition to track that and as I track
that I come into this feeling of fear
then a narrative starts to assemble
itself around the relationship between
determination and fear and I share that
narrative if it feels true in my own
body as I say it so I'm using resonance
in my own body to determine whether or
not to share something like this is
feeling true like simple way of thinking
about it I'm wearing a black shirt ooh I
feel constricted as I say it I don't
feel resonant I'm wearing a white shirt
I feel Hollow clear
I am wearing a white shirt so I'm using
that same thing to tune in the truth can
that residents also be described as
below so yeah yeah yeah run are you
interested in taking a seat here and no
no I don't know not at all you're like
no you can't yeah I don't want to know
anything other than right now period I
don't want to know who I'm gonna kill
who's gonna kill me who I'm gonna yell
at scream at to make [ __ ] happen no
thanks
what are your thoughts about what Ron
just said I'm a psychic too David
I'm not I don't share it I don't I don't
yeah I'm better off going forward not
letting people know even by saying that
I think yeah I'm just I'm very
interested to hear what other people's
thoughts are about you know Ron's just
straightforward yes Ron doesn't give a
[ __ ] enough of wine or whatever [ __ ]
people think about Ron
straightforwardness it doesn't it
doesn't care it doesn't care I think Ron
can have the last word on Ron sure let's
um let's let's we go down yeah wonderful
15 yeah that's right
all right um so you have some events
coming up in SF okay we have the center
coming up tomorrow 7:30 Center SF I'll
be doing readings much like what you
guys just saw mm-hmm in front of an
audience I'll be choosing who I read and
then answering questions and doing some
basic grounding for people that's
Tuesday and then Wednesday I'm doing
what we were talking about
with a guy named Juana Costa who'll be
putting an EEG on my head and reading it
and then a neuroscientist PhD student I
think she's about to get her PhD named
Courtney Yaeger from UCLA who's flying
up to to express what she thinks is
going on and I yeah that's what's up and
then is there anything Thursday Friday
before you leave Friday there's
something secret in the works which I'm
excited about can't reveal because it
hasn't it's not fully landed yet cool
and other than that some chilling
relaxing some homies some homies yeah
yeah cool then I fly back to New York
probably on Saturday unless something
screams that I should stay we will miss
you so much oh thank you no I'll be back
I'm excited for when you're back yeah
and I'm excited to hang out when we're
in New York next well I will this has
been a blessing that has it's been so
nice and I think that what you haven't
what we mentioned at the start with
what's gonna be happening with this just
being totally okay with the
unpredictability of where things are
going but also just like totally being
able to feel how this white male
masculine energy of mind is slowly being
like kind of shifted in a different
essence with this feminine feeling about
time isn't about time yeah yeah it's so
interesting how I'm the evolution of
humanity and civilization where it's
gone and where it's going it's just is
so interesting the human experiment so
you're amazing thank you for joining us
there thank you for having such a such a
pleasure thank you we we thank everyone
for tuning in if you guys had a good
time please give us a subscribe comment
below your thoughts give the video a
share with other people let's get more
people thinking about what it what it
feels like to feel someone else's
emotion and actually being able to take
time in our lives to be okay with that
and be safe with that
so also click on the links in the bio to
David's website join us on patreon go
and create with this information go and
make something with it and much love
everyone talk to you soon
[Music]
[Music]